les délais judiciaires en limitant la
possibilité de tenir des enquêtes
préliminaires
est ce que le gouvernement du canada va
réduire les délais et accélérer le
traitement des causes criminelles au
pays
si les délais judiciaires préoccupe
autant le gouvernement c'est bien sûr en
raison de l'arrêt jordin en 2016 la cour
suprême a dit ceci entre la première
comparution
et la décision finale du tribunal le
délai ne doit pas dépasser 18 mois ça
peut aller jusqu'à 30 mois
s'il ya une enquête préliminaire ou si
l'affairé devant la cour supérieure dans
les différentes cours provinciales du
canada environ 6% des causes criminelles
qui ont dépassé ce délai les longs
délais sont encore plus fréquent au
québec 6 17% des dossiers criminels qui
vont au delà de la durée déterminée par
l'arrêt jordin de trop longs délais au
permis entre autres à un montréalais
pourtant accusé du meurtre de sa femme
de quitter la prison sans même subir de
procès pour réduire les délais le
gouvernement fédéral veut donc limiter
la possibilité de tenir une enquête
préliminaire une enquête préliminaire
c'est quoi mais essentiellement c'est
l'audience qui permet à un juge
d'évaluer si la preuve justifie la tenue
d'un procès mais selon statistique
canada
c'est à peine 3 % de toutes les causes
criminelles qui ont fait l'objet d'une
enquête préliminaire
bref ce que dit l'association du barreau
canadien c'est que même si on limite la
possibilité de tenir des enquêtes
préliminaires saha va avoir très peu
d'impact sur les délais de procédure
dans les causes criminelles